I believe if I would I would I would say
personally like do I believe he has
concerns here hundred percent I believe
he has concerns let me tell you
something freedom is people come to us
and say Islam is against freedom of
speech look let me put it out this year
freedom freedom is speech let me tell
you something we've been coming to this
part for five years we've got people
that will come to twenty thirty years
here freedom of speech is something that
we love and we use and this is what will
actually open the minds of people
against Islam so when people come and
say another question please there's so
many questions in phone you turn by turn
one at a time I'm gonna charge in here
five pounds yeah unless I try to sit
here so just to answer your questions
Hey of course why should we strike -
speaking of course he has every right
says he has every right to convey to
speak as long as we can reply yeah so
what I'm trying to say is I believe came
to power he easy way Jefferey you have
to be unbiased Tommy go any solutions
these problems no yes but the message
that you bring yeah these great big
nobody nobody policy I've ever heard
Tommy Robert said the Japan
new mas until they are regulated which
okay I understand but this is look you
understand something if there's gradual
steps you see you have to be not you in
general a person has to be an
come on
what I'm saying this to me of concerns
hundred percent I'm hundred percent I
know as a father he has concerns just as
much I have concerns as well what we're
seeing is instead of addressing these
issues and tucking it together
he's made us and them a problem here so
grooming gangs grooming gangs is a
problem for me why is it only a problem
for you can my daughter okay Green so
I'm saying no he said he comes and makes
it seem like this is an this is what I'm
trying to say how is there a connection
okay but where is the correlation
between grooming gangs in Islam I'm
trying to find out okay one second one
second okay all right
so majority of them are Muslim okay good
that's good okay good okay let's let's
this and I'll analyze this okay they're
Muslims yeah okay the Muslims no problem
and let's see if islam teaches them this
I might use for my video with lot of
southern yeah he's from a video with
first Jada yeah they both wanted to
shake my hand
I said no yeah why did I say no good
good point so number one I could not
touch the hand of another female also
respect and right because I have a wife
yeah I'm not supposed to number two in
the Quran how many Muslims are here
drinking alcohol is a major sin it's a
major sin may just have not - in
yeah you know without women around so
they're Muslims Muslims
good point that's a very good point I'm
gonna come to that yeah so what I'm
seeing is Islam with these people who
are doing these acts they are outright
going against Islam they you know what
to do and then what to do this they
actually kind of point a middle finger
after God's law and saying I don't care
I'm gonna do what my desires one and
Islam came to abolish that and said
jihad jihad is one of the understand is
that you're in a struggle you fight
yourself I want to go and sleep around
no I feel good I shouldn't I should do
the right things so these people are
outright doing once again it's constant
so therefore it's time is against this
so let's suppose arguments say the most
that you can say it's an Asian problem
the most that you can say that is an
Asian problem however I then you come
down to pedophilia I cannot come to oh
you white guys and say go and condemn
pedophilia because the majority of them
are doing it ah nobody should know why
are you to blame for what that guy does
okay now now coming back to what you
said yeah shouldn't be covered up no I'm
against why are we throwing it under the
carpet indistinct I'm saying it should
be tackled and it shouldn't be covered
it shouldn't it shouldn't be covered no
that's wrong
it should not be covered why because we
might be branded as racist prophet
there's a problem if young girls have
been blue
you have to know no this is wrong I'm
telling you this Manish
this might be shocking to you and you I
don't believe I know it's racist never
once I've said this Tracy I said a big
is it Islamophobia I don't believe look
no no no I look there is very so
therefore you understand we're on the
same page I'm with you that Jeter
political correctness we should not
brush it under the carpet it has to be
no no no I misheard you because of
political correctness this does not mean
are just so we're not branded races Shh
let why girls get raped know that could
be my daughter I've said this before to
a father that I talked to I said if you
knew my daughter's confidence would you
do something about goes here do you
really believe I'm gonna know my
next-door neighbors girls being groomed
I'm gonna die so what girl who cares
dude I should question my humanity but
but do you understand we have something
in common
yeah and this is why we need to talk
that's why we love freedom of speech
because when we educate I know you guys
are gonna go back home and say frickin
oh man I don't know these guys were like
that so this is why communication is key
if you know how do I win you just no no
no no I be against freedom speech okay
no no no they're against freedom speech
don't fight brand fascist say one more
time and if I only see fascism when it's
white clearly is in the you you care
about Muslims in the community right I
care about everyone like when there is a
problem when Islam is being seen in a
bad light yeah I care about that right
and I understand like when it comes to
these grooming gangs and they're out
there they are missed and people doing
it and you I'm not I'm not I'm not
inside
I'm not saying as an Islamic thing right
I'm saying that shouldn't it be up to
people in the community to do it easy
people don't identify this using I'm not
saying if you go around the sea use
things and use what is what though use
things in no they'll try new things in
the in like in some of the scripture no
yes they will it's up to people it's
upset Imams it's absolute scholars to
this own then right that's an issue
fatwas against against what certain
people are doing in the name of its no
no no no self-regulate no you go in
socially wouldn't reach or max you go
Manresa Muslim saying what what is what
is what is Haram and what is halal right
yeah because you want you want because
obviously I have a right if they're
going to be a Muslim and live a
righteous life right now so when there
are Muslims who are not living in in
what your opinion is a righteous line
yeah I totally agree that these people
are not actually an Islamic way yeah but
it is up to the community to issue
fatwas against them to say that they're
not acting in the name of of Islam you
are acting in a in a in a on Islamic way
and anatomically the thing is is that
they are people off of the Muslim
community who are doing not all of them
but a lot of them are and only in
networks yeah on that point these
Muslims who do these acts they already
know that the community they know where
they stand when it comes to Islam in the
community and Muslim boys who have
girlfriends they hide from their family
hard here community just when they got a
girlfriend yeah they're long winded
grooming so they already know they
already know where the Commission sorry
very sorry
so these grooming gangs when they do
these acts they're hiding from their own
community the do because they know Islam
don't approve of it their mom knows
their for me know they see me they'll
get their game Batman yeah are you
asking for the
that's happening because you guys look
I'm gonna talk about can we talk about
probably I've said this before I said
what are you ready to me are you going
to be I wanna [ __ ] you wanted you can't
this is no yes or no answer is context
this is the context exactly okay UK was
a pedophile countries
[Applause]
yes he's been running away for one whole
yeah I have to chase him he's mean it
shows anyone this book teaches 233
verses one verse tell me one verse 153
one verse one
not on jihad the next door even trace
him yeah okay
I said I'll write that he then why is
your nose knock him up no c'mon people
look him up he comes today if he comes
if he comes and says these Aquifer they
should be cute ugly fun what
[Music]
[Music]
you know because you know we are the
ones so this imagine there's a line yeah
look we the British public are on one
side we're here just trying to tackle
extremism and Jim Chowdhury Isis
far-right groups that Tommy Robinson
Britain first are on this side I'm not
saying that exactly equivalent Isis
because Isis all right
just closer to madness and kills Muslims
they kill Muslims a blow up most clear
they're on one side saying preaching
hate you suffers we suffer you end up
being run over or I end up getting run
over y ou look apart or no Muslim they
wanna take over infidel blah blah we are
the ones who are getting run over and
I'm here to stop that because if we
don't more people are gonna die like you
and like me at the hands of these people
who are pocketed money and you know for
their own agenda by speaking out against
it